what kinds of books do you want in
schools in libraries books that educate
children
that's a generalization that the books
that don't have pornography in them
let's start there let's just put the bar
really really low books that don't have
incest pedophilia never bet against a
mom I mean nobody's going to defend
anything like a mom is going to defend
their child we want people who are
serving an elected office that respect
the role of the parent in a child's life
they lie about don't say gay and what
what's happening with the books and all
of those things even now they're like oh
I guess we can't totally hide this but
the point here guys is that something
positive comes when you tell the truth